sensation sensations le mag
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
sensation en partenariat avec tv 60,18
je reçois aujourd'hui dominique benhaim
responsable de la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonjour
bonjour alors la commanderie organise et
communiquent sur toutes les activités
les rendez vous à ne pas manquer sur le
territoire quels sont les objectifs au
quotidien de la commanderie écoutez
c'est de retrouver un public le plus
large possible c'est à dire partir de 3
4 ans jusqu'à prix d'âge est de leur
proposer différentes activités dans
différents domaines alors elle la crise
sanitaire a perturbé à la tenue de
certains événements pour autant vous
avez pu continuer certaines activités la
saison débute ce mois de septembre
quelles sont vos ambitions pour cette
nouvelle saison écouter avant tout c'est
de donner envie au public de nous
retrouver et de retrouver la commanderie
bien évidemment on a pu maintenir depuis
fin mai un certain nombre de
propositions dont le cinéma en plein air
cet été dont la journée l'échappée belle
fin juin ce qui a permis de quand même
retrouvé un lien après le confinement et
toute cette grande période de
télétravail qu'on a tous eu donc on
espère tous les retrouver dès le 11
septembre à la commanderie est alors
justement est ce que vous avez pu avoir
ce sentiment que les gens avaient besoin
de se retrouver il avait besoin il avait
envie parce que justement les a
retrouvés sur le peu d'événements qu'on
a pu mettre en place en juin et puis cet
été entre auto aussi laissé les vacances
qu'ils étaient des stages pour les
enfants tout le long du mois de juillet
qui était complet tous on a bien vu que
les gens avaient envie de renouer avec
ce lieu et avec les différentes
activités proposées et alors on va
parler de la programmation du mois de
septembre la saison commence le 11
septembre avec l'événement ou welcome de
17 heures à minuit alors quel est le
programme de cette journée à welcome
c'est effectivement notre ouverture de
saison
et là on essaie de faire différentes
propositions pareil en famille entre
amis pour les jeunes pour les moins
jeunes dans tous les domaines que
propose la commanderie c'est à dire les
arts visuels les écritures
contemporaines les sciences la danse
voilà on essaie que les gens viennent et
puissent picorer par moments s'installer
à d'autres moments tranquillement et de
profiter de cette programmation qui est
assez riche autant avec des impromptus
théâtraux avec un atelier de peinture en
direct avec un spectacle de jonglage et
mathématiques oui jonglage une matière
éthique ça a très bien ensemble et un
grand temps fort dense et en fin de
journée qui nous le souhaitons se
terminera par un dj set et on attend
tout le monde pour danser et prendre du
plaisir à la commanderie en septembre et
alors justement on le voit vous voulez
avoir des activités et d une
programmation qui se veut à la fois
festive mais aussi ludique c'est
important justement pour vous de ramener
toujours un petit peu de 2,2 ludique
dans vos activités c'est très important
parce que le lait là c'est tout ce que
fait la culture c'est tout ce mélange
c'est autant de devoir peut-être une
proposition un peu plus pointue en
sciences en danse de voir une exposition
d'un artiste mais aussi d'avoir des
moments un peu plus festif où on se
retrouve et on a envie de découvrir le
reste du programme du coup alors du 11
au 19 septembre un atelier de danse est
organisé avec la chorégraphe joanne
leighton et sa compagnie w lnd ça
s'appelle médine sky c'est un atelier
pour apprendre et pratiquer la danse
alors pas vraiment c'est en fait alors
c'est un projet déjà ce important qui
est menée en partenariat avec le théâtre
de saint quentin la scène nationale est
en fait ce qu'on appelle un projet
participatif on a énormément de public
est friand de ce genre de projet c'est à
dire de venir auprès d'un chorégraphe
professionnel à prendre en fait mais une
chorégraphie et et donner des
représentations
et donc joanne leighton sera accompagné
de quatre de ses danseuses et les
participants vont pouvoir avoir un
certain nombre d'ateliers qui auront
lieu à au théâtre de saint quentin et la
restitution les deux représentations
auront lieu à la commanderie est alors
pour les amoureux de la photographie une
exposition est mise en place du 11
septembre au 3 octobre vous présentez
donc l'exposition hors champ de
christian l'hôte et que nous réserve
cette exposition
christian c'est d'abord un photographe
qu'on ne connaît depuis très très
longtemps je dirais que c'est un
photographe de la couleur
voilà il nous propose à nous proposer en
fait une
une cinquantaine de clichés couleur donc
bien évidemment qui vont représenter à
peu près 20 ans de son travail
donc on lui a laissé libre choix on a eu
vraiment à coeur de présenter ses photos
son travail en tant qu artiste
photographe donc je vous laisse venir
découvrir l'exposition la commande c'est
un coup de coeur finalement pour vous
cet artiste oui c'est un travail quand
le travail de christian le suit depuis
très longtemps elle aime beaucoup et
c'était une occasion de lui proposer de
venir exposer la commande d'ailleurs
chaque année vous c'est un
incontournable et vous ne passez pas à
côté je parle des journées européennes
du patrimoine c'est le 18 et 19
septembre vous êtes en collaboration
avec le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines
quel est le programme de ces deux
journées quelles sont vos ambitions pour
les journées européennes du patrimoine
effectivement net en partenariat avec le
musée à la commanderie mais le musée a
en charge énormément de propositions
pendant tout le week-end sur tout le
territoire de saint quentin nous nous
allons leur proposer proposé aux
spectateurs déjà des visites guidées par
une conférencière de la commanderie
venir tout connaître de l'architecturé
et de l'histoire de la commanderie et de
pouvoir du coup accéder à des bâtiments
on n'a pas forcément accès d'habitude
facilement on va proposer aussi des
ateliers pour les plus jeunes autour du
portrait autour des fouilles autour de
l'archéologie et c'est dans le cadre des
journées du patrimoine le dimanche aura
lieu la restitution du projet made in
saint quentin
proposé par joanne leighton et les 99
amateurs vous l'avez un petit peu dire
justement il ya des choses pour les
enfants des choses pour les adultes des
choses pour la famille c'est votre votre
intérêt premier on va dire de créer
justement ce côté partage familial
partage familial mais surtout partage
doute pour tous les âges voilà que
chacun vienne trouver quelque chose qui
lui corresponde à la commanderie alors
on poursuit avec le 22 septembre un
atelier d'écriture est organisée avec
thierry casals les participants devront
apprendre l'écriture du haïku alors
j'espère que je le prononce bien à
écouter ce que le ibook alors le heiko
maas est la forme la plus courte de
poèmes qui existent sans verre sans
pardon sans rimes excusez-moi droit vers
ce qu'elles sont en verre trop inverse
sans rimes et c'est la forme la plus
courte qui existent en poésie donc
effectivement les participants vont
apprendre à écrire des haïkus mais alors
c'est qu'est ce que c'est un atelier
réservé aux adultes ou est ce que les
enfants pourront également apprendre non
justement il va proposer un atelier pour
les enfants pour les 9 14 ans et un
atelier pour adultes ce qui leur
permettra de d'étudier différents
domaines mais alors vous finissez le
mois avec deux stages de danse un
atelier danse e par enfant et une
initiation à la danse gumboot sont
prévues le 25 septembre à la commanderie
pouvez vous nous présenter ces deux
ateliers on va commencer par le stage
par enfant oui c'est l'atelier on aime
bien mettre en lien avec des expositions
avec des spectacles ateliers parents
enfants qui sont dirigés tous par des
chorégraphes professionnels
là en l'occurrence et doria bélanger qui
va être l'artiste associé à la danse à
la commanderie pendant un an qui va nous
présenter son exposition joule joule ça
va être un système de vidéo où elle fait
interagir des images qu'elle a pu filmer
de
grandir de générateurs d'énergie que soi
et éolienne barrages etc et les danseurs
en miroir qui ont dansé face à ces
propositions d'énergie ça ces
expositions joule et du coup on a
demandé à d'aurillac et donc et vidéaste
et chorégraphe de proposer en lien avec
son exposition un atelier parents
enfants autour donc d énergie alors pour
la danse gumboot du coup car le guen
boudent ça vient d'afrique du sud c'est
cette danse qui est tapé donc gumboot
c'est à dire les grosses bottes en
caoutchouc et donc qui est fait et qui
fait résonner sans arrêt qui est une
danse fait de percussions et entre
autres donc de percussions avec ses
grosses bottes en caoutchouc donc ça
sera une initiation au cameroun on en
parle depuis le début de cette émission
le partage la volonté justement de
partage et de faire découvrir est ce que
justement le partage à travers la
culture c'est finalement important et
c'est ce qui nous a manqué ces derniers
mois en tout cas c'est ce qui a manqué à
beaucoup de gens on a eu pour cela
beaucoup de messages et ça on en était
ravi et et je remercie tous tous tous
ceux qui nous ont écrit pour nous
soutenir pour nous dire qu'ils avaient
envie de nous retrouver et je pense que
oui ça à manquer à beaucoup de gens à la
fois d'apprendre en s'amusant à la fois
la rencontre à la fois le d'être
ensemble et de partager ensemble soit
des spectacles des ateliers des
rencontres alors on a parlé de la
programmation la commanderie mais vous
êtes en collaboration avec les
différents acteurs culturels indue du
territoire pour proposer ou relayer des
évident des événements et des spectacles
pourquoi est ce que c'est important
finalement de se mettre en relation
entre tous les acteurs du territoire
pour permettre d'avoir une un panel
finalement à proposer aux citoyens et
parce que déjà on est un territoire
donc c'est important et que c'est une
des missions de la commanderie la
commanderie est un équipement de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc un
équipement territorial et donc c'est
très important pour nous soit de mettre
en place des projets avec les différents
partenaires culturels non comme vous le
disiez soit de relayer et d'accueillir à
la commanderie des propositions de nos
partenaires mais pour plus
d'informations et pour les réservations
ça se passe sur le site la commanderie
point ski point fr merci beaucoup
dominique beinheim d'avoir est avec nous
sur sensations je rappelle que vous êtes
la responsable de la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez vous
sur notre site et applications radio
sensations
[Musique]
et